في نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه وجدت
اليابان نفسها مرغمه على القبول بدستور
فردته الولايات المتحده تنبذ الفقره
التاسعه منه الحربكه وسيله لتسويه
النزاعات لذا منعت اليابان من تشكيل جيش
واسست بدلا منهما سميت بقوات الدفاع
الذاتي لكنها ممنوعه من ارسال قوه الى
الخارج ومن المشاركه في ترتيبات الامن
والدفاع الجماعي بناء على ذلك تبنت
اليابان ضمن سياستها الدفاعيه ثلاثه مبادئ
تحضر عليها تصنيعها او امتلاك اسلحه نوويه
كما تحضر صادرات الاسلحه والمعدات
الدفاعيه وثالث هذه المبادئ هو الحد من
انفاقها الدفاعي حيث لا يتجاوز واحدا في
المئه من الناتج المحلي سنويا اما الان في
المراجعه الجديده للسياسه الدفاعيه
اليابانيه توصف بالاكبر منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتمثل تحطيما للقيود
التي ضلت توقرها القوانين اليابانيه رغم
التعديلات الطفيفه خلال العقود الماضيه
سقف الانفاق العسكري سيرتفع الى الضعف
لتصير الميزانيه الدفاعيه السنويه للبلاد
2% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي بحلول عام
وتصبح بذلك اليابان صاحبه الثالث اكبر
ميزانيه عسكريه في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده والصين بينما ستودع قوات الدفاع
الذاتي البريه والبحريه والجويه ذات
الصلاحيات المحدوده تحت قياده موحد في حضن
خمس سنوات
تقضي السياسه الدفاعيه الجديده بامتلاك
قدره على شكل هجوم مضاد باسلحه يمكن ان
تستهدف مواقع اطلاق صواريخ العدو وباتت
الصين وروسيا وكوريا الشماليه مصدر قلق
كبير وتهديد لليابان مع اعتبار الصين اكبر
تحدي اسيراتيجي لسلام اليابان واستقرارها
التوجه الجديد لقي ثناءا امريكيه فقد قال
وزير الخارجيه
اليابان تتلاقى مع الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
قدره التحالف بين البلدين على حمايه
النظام القائم على القواعد في منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادي